she's in red the rumors are starting
already oh and we've got matching eyes -
hey pop Oh having a purple moment on a
red thumb and what can it mean what can
I mean then will be my lightsaber color
no I didn't that makes Windu yes now Joe
I gotta tell you Joe I was asking John
to give superlatives he voted how did
you best for him what would so I would
say it's the best five head because you
know usually it's four on the thing I
could fit five fingers on my head it's a
running joke that my head is very large
so when I saw it on Sunset Boulevard I
was like how did this get bigger it's
like big head big teeth
my two best qualities most beautiful
woman on Hollywood Boulevard okay you've
seen the movie yeah what was your
reaction what was the face you made when
the credits me and then we all sort of
sat around a bit stunned and then I was
trying to scurry off into the car to cry
and Michelle regimen and Chris are like
no going okay I know and then I had to
watch some friends to wind down it's a
lot it moves super far so it's like
super snappy so you're sort of like so
tuned in that we really didn't process
it till the end because suddenly you're
like oh oh my gosh yeah I'm assuming you
cried because you loved it it's very
overwhelming to see yourself on screen
and it is very overwhelming like we had
already started pressed for it so like
you know the words ringing in your ears
of how does it feel that it's the last
one there's so many sort of like ends
that other people are talking about you
suddenly are like oh my god it's the
last one so I think more than ever now I
feel oh my god this is it not to add to
that but just to take a trip down memory
lane
memory lane we were standing in this
very spot four years ago I think it was
just like a sea of stormtroopers I was
terrified I was shaking my agent
promises were like eat something and I
was eating like rice in the carcass I
was as I am now shivering and sweaty
that really attractive combination like
a super fever yeah but I feel more
nervous this time and why I don't know I
don't know I think I like I'm aware more
of the process I was like more present
the whole time so I feel more than ever
it's out of my hands cuz I know there's
nothing I could do so then it feels
weird to like take that step into
sharing it because it's like ours now
and then like three hours it will be
everyone else's she's going head-to-head
with Palpatine maybe Ian's here
somewhere I think lovely man the
antithesis of Palpatine
[Music]